la semaine dernière on était devant un
café on avait était tombé par hasard sur
un passant qui avait un amour à t-shirt
rappelle antoine palatis cher paddle
stade français est pas une vilenie sympa
paddle de sur les tennis qui tant est
que vous avez défié encore un qui ce cas
où c'est l'arrogance de l'effort
l'effort et donc du coup on vous étiez
donné rendez vous samedi après on s'est
tous retrouvés samedi après midi au
stade français pour un match vous et
votre compère qui est très bien c'est
lent excellent niveau en manuel manub
armes contre antoine et son comparse
aussi qu'un ancien de saint juste
horrible j'ai appris ça après exactement
et kg prof de tennis va exactement kevin
qui est vivant qu'est bac était fort
alors ne manquez pas les commentaires de
raymond il ya maxime qui élargit le cas
qu'ils font peut-être leur entrée dans
l'émission ça serait sympathique colisée
aussi oui à maxime et j'y vois la con
qui bien entendu qui eux seront avec
nous également l'année prochaine alors
qu'est ce qui se passe alors là on doit
voir quoi marrant de voir les images du
match honnête honnêtement eux et ils ont
pris une fessée moi j'ai pris une claque
tableau listant les images voix hachée
pas une mode ondines
[Musique]
c'est un handicap
quelqu'un touché par la grâce comme
cyril c'est pas la peine d'essayer de me
contrer il faut le regarder
voilà qui gagne chef on va très disputé
mais malgré tout il ya pas une grosse
mainmise ces villes seront des
adversaires
[Musique]
on aurait indiqué aux machos siècle
c'est à dire longtemps signalé michel
bernard non alors
sachez joué très très bien et wade kevin
aurait eu un peu de chance et c'est
grâce à manu un shérif voilà qu'on a on
a gagné qui a été exceptionnel un monde
a écrit une nouvelle page
je n'ai encore les poils regarder on n'a
pas bien vu la ban voilà merci joe cobra
et il c'est vrai que non mais merci
d'être venus en tout cas merci et
surtout merci antoine qui a été fabuleux
et il va proposer donc il m'a dit
maintenant il me défie au tennis finales
il croit que je passais tous et avec
grand plaisir
ce qui m'a fait rire c'est que et jean
michel et bernard ils ont fait tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient pour vous se faire
remarquer pendant que vous jouiez est
alors cyrine ne voyez mais strictement
personne il était surtout un jeu c'est
un métier archi bien sûr michel fait
plaisir vous venir
oui oui mais vous aimez gagner un
connaisseur faire don du sang fut ardu
il y avait moi y avait mon maximum je
suis devenu mon chéri d'amour quand tu
fais un sport sans prévenir
merci mon chéri qui est avec moi après
jusqu'à la fin oui sophy mais ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que vont ils avaient
effectivement le type que vous avez
défié mais il est venu avec un
partenaire passage tout forcément doublé
quand on a vu arriver le partenaire
alors il ya 25 ans 1 m 90 kg a choisi 46
à l'air mignon nayagom un golgoth ah
ouais tu me karine ouais on s'est dit
bon c'est pas gagné gagné en plus mes
proches je crois à hauteur de padel dans
de tennis ça se rejoint mais bon voilà
c'est pas lui qui avait les jambes les
plus belles un bébé c'est vous et
antoine tribunes et des jambes assez
maigre par rapport au reste du pays
allez bon merci en tout cas voilà on a
relevé le défi mon chéri si vous avez
d'autres défis à nous proposer des idées
au long des séries vous êtes classé qui
vient maintenant au paddle genève un
canard mais avec 2 citrons avec le corps
la mére moi une très bonne phrase qui
m'a appelé ce week-end qu'est ce qui
s'est passé non moi j'ai bien aimé parce
que d'un mec dans la rue comme ça qui
vous lance un défi on se retrouve au
stade français il joue avec vous et où
après voilà moi j'ai beaucoup charrier
les mecs mais il était bien habillé
j'avoue j'ai j'avoue qu'ils s'étaient
bien dhabi
mais ils ont pris 6 3 6 4 mais si naze
ils ont tout misé sur la taille ils ont
tout misé sur la tenue surtout misé sur
la tête même pas chauffé vous avez gardé
votre blouson même pas monter en
température
l'échauffement chauffe moment donné
j'étais obligé il avait une canette dans
la poche et crée de la voiture je dois
moi tout ça ça ça rien de joli tout ça
maintenant c'est bon je vais pas pour
nous proposer d'autres défis qu'ont les
relèvera